ladies and gentlemen all that glitters
is not gold
sometimes the people faking a perfect
lifestyle like
jinsha of the real housewives really are
running a
secret crime ring behind the scenes
in this town i'm queen bee and mvp
a real housewife is now facing federal
charges along with her assistant
on suspicion of running a nationwide
telemarketing fraud
and money laundering scheme she's
accused
in a doj release of conspiracy to commit
wire fraud
money laundering it is crazy and we're
gonna get into
all of it today i was up late last night
trying to dig into this
and figure out what was going on because
honestly listen
i've learned that what is shown in the
press release and what is actually has
actually happened or two different
things
there's a lot that wasn't said and i
tried to dig up some of it for you guys
to give you the most
context for this kind of insane um
indictment of one of the big celebrities
on like
reality tv recently guys again a
reminder
you can't trust these people you can't
trust them at all
all these influencers and you can stop
smiling
and being a [ __ ] [ __ ] because you
are yeah you are
and koa handled this okay this is her
behind the scenes
hey this is kind of what you get if
you're going to talk like a crime boss
maybe you're going to go to jail i don't
know you don't have a [ __ ] attitude
with me
[Music]
this week shut the [ __ ] up okay yeah i'm
not too surprised by this
anyway let's roll the intro huh ladies
and gentlemen welcome to coffeezilla
the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host and today of course
we're going over these charges like
obviously um
i want to keep you guys informed with
what's going on okay
now to talk about jennifer's shot we
have to start from the beginning
she became a real housewife star uh
when it was found that she lived a
lavish lifestyle she had a husband
that was the coach of a football team
and generally she fit the profile
of someone who's entertaining bombastic
you know seems to have all this wealth
who is she no one could figure out what
she did
she talked about being rich because of
direct response marketing
and a few other things but she's always
vague about where her
money came from business side we have a
bunch of exciting
exciting stuff shaw beauty just launched
we have
a new like entrepreneur program for
women where we're helping women
pivot and shift their business through
the quarantine and covid
she's basically a guru she's basically a
fake guru she's like hey i'm gonna help
you guys
like isn't it funny that all these
entrepreneurs who end up getting caught
for some kind of front
a lot of them were doing some kind of
coaching scam too and we have a new
product called
fixture because of course gen shaw would
have a product called that
whoa whoa whoa wait did you just create
a product called fixture and did you
just refer to yourself in the third
person
i think she deserves to go to jail just
for that
that's straight up how can you say that
listen
all in all all these uh explanations for
how she made her money a beauty line
direct response marketing
some kind of business coaching thing
that wasn't how she made her money
instead according to this indictment she
had a telemarketing scheme
where she would call a bunch of old
people and try to get them
on the hook for a bunch of scam services
they say
to perpetuate the business opportunity
scheme
they sold alleged services purporting to
make the management
of victims businesses more efficient or
profitable geez where have we heard that
idea before
including tax preparation website design
services notwithstanding that many
victims
were elderly and did not own a computer
they're selling website design
to people who don't own a computer
apparently a lot of the people were
uh old very very old as we see a lot of
the telemarketing scams
that's who they cater to important to
this indictment by the way is that
at no point did the defendants intend
that the victims would actually earn
any of the promised return on their
intended investment nor did the victims
actually earn such
returns now that's really interesting uh
because of what we're about to find out
because she tried to hide this
she wanted the appearance of being like
this star
on camera living this lavish lifestyle
but she didn't want people to know where
the money was coming from because
clearly
it wasn't coming coming from a beauty
line it's coming from this scam scheme
so how did they hide it well actually
ginshaw is one of the more sophisticated
fraudsters we've seen
see she took significant efforts to
conceal their roles in the business
opportunity scheme
it's her and her assistant by the way
who are indicted um they incorporated
their business entities using
third-party names
and instructed other participants to do
the same
and used and directed others to use
encrypted messaging apps
to communicate with other participants
so listen it's not like they didn't know
they were committing fraud that's the
thing here
the fact that you're using a bunch of
encrypted messaging apps the fact that
you're
registering these businesses and
third-party names the fact that
you're communicating with other
participants and instructing them to
send
your share of certain fraud proceeds to
offshore bank accounts
hey you know you're committing fraud
hey by the way i just found this clip
look at how she describes what she does
because she calls herself the wizard of
oz like behind the curtain that no one
knows about
knowing now what she did it cast this in
such a sinister light salt lake city
so how do you live the life you and your
husband have such a lavish
lifestyle where is all this money coming
from
so i it's funny because a lot of the
ladies are like oh my gosh
where does jen get all her money and i
think part of it is like
here in utah the ladies are like oh my
gosh how does the brown girl and the
black husband have all this money
because that's you know what i mean
they're like no don't bring race into it
no it's just because no one your
businesses aren't public you're
rich but you no one knows what you do i
am like i own
three different marketing companies and
what do you do lead generation
data monetization so it's customer
acquisition
yeah i'm basically scammed the best way
to describe it is i'm the wizard of oz
i'm like the one behind the curtain that
nobody knows exists but i'm the one
making everything happen
wow wow you could play that in court
like literally i bet you that will be
played in court by the way i'm the
person behind the curtain nobody sees me
but i'm the one making things happen
jeez dude
bang the gavel you're guilty all right
guys so what can we learn from all of
this
jinsha yes a lot of people are surprised
by this
but uh honestly i'm not look someone
pops out of nowhere
they're mysteriously making all this
cash and no one can find the businesses
that they're supposedly making the cash
from
something's up of course it is
somebody's living some lavish lifestyle
on instagram and there's no explanation
for how they made their money are we
surprised when it comes out they're
committing fraud
typically well to do people like this uh
are under prosecuted and they don't get
a lot of jail time so i wouldn't be
surprised to see her get out on like six
months
it's sad but true i mean we just don't
care when it's a rich person committing
fraud
when it's a poor person robbing from a
store five bucks
hey you might be going to the slammer
for a while but when it's a rich per
person defrauding old people
well what's the harm i don't know it's
kind of like a sad reality of
the modern criminal system white collar
crime is horribly
under sentenced so anyway that's
basically it thanks for watching
don't forget to pump the stock and i'll
see you guys
tomorrow i know what you need this ain't
what it seems
nothing but a trick trying to tell me on
a dream but that was where you lost
wake up and me the coffee